[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about
whatever we want what's up hello honeys
i i feel
on cloud nine right now because we're
finally proving that david and i are not
the same person that's pretty crazy oh i
was telling her off camera the funniest
comment that i read was like
if somebody told david to go [ __ ]
himself he could just [ __ ] sharon cola
i mean this is off the record this is
off the record let's just get to it
you guys are the same person they think
we look alike do you all
think so honestly sometimes honestly you
guys could be brothers or sisters
yeah yeah no question is it i was your
and bobby
lee's love child yes i see that that's
what i was
we're here to squash them once and for
all what are the what's the truth
the the biggest rumor is that geo and i
have a little thing going on oh [ __ ]
italian oh good technique oh is that
good
your technique you gotta firm up the
geo is so fine oh enough of this please
my
word we just started our day
this is not going well know i have never
felt
so hot in my life why what
temperature wise can you explain like
just the beauty of like
owning every single one of your layers
and like feeling liberated to live out
loud
[Laughter]
she's from a different part of l.a yo
you got a
west atlantic culture i don't know what
to say not over here pal
is this a lifetime speech you're about
to give no
inauguration speech she says she like i
love that for you like we don't say that
on this side of element
we don't say that well i'm from the side
of la so i'm just fighting that balance
teach me the language of that land what
does this mean you're from this side but
then you move to the west side and then
they absorbed you you know me peer
pressure peer pressure because over here
it's
must be nice food yeah yeah it must be
nice for
everything must be nice it must be nice
to know who you really are and [ __ ]
at somebody's dinner party and they're
like it's really nice to own all your
layers and i'm like i'm going to go
the only foods to go
what does that mean to online layers you
know your identities
yeah and being proud of it and embracing
it and celebrating it
this is straight from a fortune cookie
straight from the
fortune cookies no that should be a
thing
gabriel fortune cookies it's only
multicolored and [ __ ]
perfect what what's the fortune that
would be in there yes [ __ ]
you know it's not even a fortune it's
just a statement
what the [ __ ] that would make me happy
though
[ __ ] it like wave it leave it like a
flag really [ __ ] good idea yeah
ready fortune cookies yeah it's a
rainbow fortune cookie
well i can't do what i'm saying well
technically in canada you're going to
put on a wig and i'm pretty sure
we technically own those ideas right now
fortune cookies are straight
well y'all no let's cancel
fortune no wait how are they straight
loki
you just called us out you're right we
we assumed we assumed we assumed that
fortunately
we zoomed out the layers steve what's
the [ __ ] we assumed that hetero
ness i wanted to cancel them they look
pretty gay to me
i mean they look like a [ __ ] right yes
fortune cookies look like a shaved [ __ ]
do you guys do you guys eat eat fortune
cookies or no i love
yup do you eat it or do you crack it and
eat it i eat
i eat it first and then i can read it
yes you eat it before you read it just
like when girls have sex with each other
cunnilingus and then book club no do you
i mean do you break it
or do you bite into it i bite it i break
it and then i pull it out and then i go
like that oh
magician i pull it out
i don't even eat it because i like it
it's just out of habit no it's like the
good
the flavors of whatever like vanilla or
something you can't find that flavor
anywhere no one wants to make that bread
vanilla you can find vanilla everywhere
what are you talking about
vanilla's the one flavor you can find
everywhere you can go into a home depot
be like
i'll get the vanilla um
no i actually really like the flavor but
yeah i i don't read it
until i [ __ ] eat it even if i'm not
in the mood i'm superstitious so i have
to [ __ ] force myself to eat it
and then read it i was doing it i was
doing it the wrong way one time and this
old gypsy woman corrected me
what's the wrong way she said no no no
no no no
no she's disappeared under your table
she smoked yeah you appear from inside
the fortune cookie
read your palm uh
panda express hooks you up with like
four of them you eat all four of them
no i choose one and the other three
throw away i've never gotten four love
really it feels like you wanted to eat
first of all they would never give you
four if they're real chinese they hook
you up
no they count the people in your party
and they're like we're gonna give you
exactly what
i'll come for jk news sometimes we'll
have like six of them because there's
six people sitting here
extra six extra oh then then the
management selects you
you dump him in he's right they dump him
in i actually have a question for you
right only because i you showed us some
pictures of you on dates right
so you're bisexual do you
do your makeup differently depending on
what gender that you meet up with
because what i've noticed too is that
when you were with the male you you
looked more feminine
and then with the girl you didn't
interesting question very interesting
question
i happened to look feminine that day
because i took him to an event
so um i was glammed up i had the glam uh
i did see
i don't want to say too much here tell
us all your layers
no one's watching anyway girls um uh it
really depends on
what i look like that day like i happen
to
see the girl another day um where i
happen to have makeup on
so i don't know how to wear makeup like
so
just for the record i mean i know how to
wear it i don't know how to do it i
never grew up girly whatever it may be
um someone else got to put it on you
yeah i don't even know how to do it
period but who did your makeup on and
then like a glam team
okay
no that's the thing the only times i
wear makeup is when i'm doing tv when
i'm doing events or whatever like
there's people doing glass hair makeup
that's the only time i thought you were
like kim kardashian every day you wake
up you have a whole team making you
beautiful no only when there's like an
occasion so
um it depends but yeah i am very
comfortable looking like how i look like
like the
the guy for example thinks i'm [ __ ]
bomb it's about just like this that's
right so does the girl and if i happen
to have makeup then i do you know what i
mean yeah
um but but there is something about that
though because
i do think oh maybe guys like um what
about clothing choices then
also interesting yeah do you have like
things that are more accentuating or
no i'd never accentuate i this is me you
know yeah i think
sriracha myself
[Laughter]
wow
in her face
what the [ __ ] going on
um so it is interesting though because
like i say i lost my train of thought um
the way you dress and the way you look
situation well just in general i don't
really dress in form fitting clothes
you know like the most is like i'll show
some boob sometimes
it's like boobs if you have it you have
it but girls love boobs too
yeah you know so it's like that's
universal i think i just i stay pretty
true i stay pretty true
um what is interesting though i don't
know if we talked about the last time
but like
i am such a gentle woman when it comes
to females because i'm like
you know i know what we deserve we
should be treated like queens and like
just enjoy life what does that feel like
he treats you like a queen when you talk
about like an old egyptian queen who
didn't have air conditioning
yeah and they they lived in like a stone
house right there you go yeah
yeah just just ladies out there just
make sure you [ __ ] treat me good
because i took one for the [ __ ] team
cheers cheers for that yeah thank you
for that yeah let's [ __ ] talk to that
she stepped in cat [ __ ] this morning i
don't know who the [ __ ] she's talking
about
you said the cat [ __ ] i did i do love
uh just like balling out
for a girl because it's just like you
know what does that feel so you do
definitely
you you have different tactics then
right it's interesting because like i'm
still
even i still have like you know with all
my you know [ __ ]
uh spiritual [ __ ] i'm still sometimes
in that mindset of like oh wait i don't
wanna
hurt the male ego if i'm like oh i got
this like maybe he should treat me
it's weird it's weird this game of that
hetero like like allowing allowing the
guy to do
male things like pay for the bill do guy
[ __ ] like i'll i'll
i'll allow it because i like it in that
case see like the tradition
taking a girl out i want to pay so it's
just like i wear the pants then i take
them off
that's interesting when your
relationship with women is you take over
the masculine and with men you take over
the feminine role
sure in those old school labels um
but it's so fluid now you know like we
so what i realized is like you know what
[ __ ] it if i want to treat him then i'll
treat him because
oh my god i'm saying way too much i hope
they don't watch this um but he does
you're fine
basically this channel is failing don't
worry about it
they don't know the people you know but
you're hanging on the edge of a cliff
right now yeah you're fine
i'm here to singly save uh
yeah for example no i literally brought
my hammer um
these are fluorescent lights it's just
daylight it's funny i don't know that
this monday this is the music video for
michelle brandy
don't worry about it today's video is
brought to you by babble
so you know i recently went to mexico
yeah
to habla espanol poquito muy bien
thanks to babel i got to learn a little
bit of espanol
uh maybe as much as bobby hill's mom but
i think it helped me just enough for me
to get around town
and i think from this point on before i
go to a certain country
i'm gonna be using babel to brush up on
that language or even learn it
a little bit so when i'm there i can
practice and
i think that you can connect more with
the culture when you do that
and i actually like babble's approach
because they use
words and phrases and teach you in a way
that's very applicable like how to
navigate restaurants to find where the
bathroom is
so it's stuff that you can learn and
immediately
apply to wherever you're going because i
before was taking spanish from like this
cd and it was teaching me like how to
say business card
or a lawyer and when you're going on a
vacation you usually
aren't looking for a lawyer you're
usually just going like hey where's the
food at where's the bathroom at
how hey how are you doing what's the
price and they have all these language
experts to help determine what you
should be learning first
unless you go to mexican jail then
you're going to need a little lawyer yes
you're going to need a lot
more than just a lawyer also what i
liked about it is the lessons are like
15 minutes
so if you do a little bit every day you
can pick up and it's not like this
whole extensive long mentally draining
process and with babble you can choose
from over 14
different languages from spanish french
italian german
there's wherever you want to go you
could probably find a course that
teaches you that language
and right now they have a special deal
when you go to babel.com and you
purchase three months
you get another three months for free
that is
six months for the price of three go to
babel.com that's
e l dot b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash off the
record babble.com
off the record b-a-b-b-e-l dot com slash
off the record tunisia is the is the
game different though like
text game even like when you talk to
like the you know some people like to
play games or whatever is it different
flirty
we should even do it just role play it
yeah go yeah oh yeah
yeah say something okay go oh go let's
try someone else have fun
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no it's
gotta be fun
we need why do you want it to be
successful
the worst guy possible all right so are
you texting me first i'll text you first
exactly hello w h-e-w-w-o hello
oh i'm wet dude so how dry is your [ __ ]
right now
he's done that to me okay unfortunately
my [ __ ] is
like literally never dry the libido has
has never been
so good i am it works on some people it
is
like it is soak city this summer like
soaks
i think it's because of like you know so
many factors
raging waters up in this [ __ ] like um
san dimas no shoes in the pool
type b you know what i mean i when is
shoes in the pool okay yeah
at raising water i'm [ __ ] traumatized
because i went to raging waters when i
was little
a [ __ ] kid comes down the slide with
shoes off what the [ __ ]
like it felt like spice girl's platform
heals okay in the face
oh in my face and so i'm traumatized by
water did you ever see a kid go down
like surrounded with his own [ __ ]
because he [ __ ] himself
yeah yeah that's why i don't go to
raiders you saw that i saw it wild
oh my god i'm waiting to hear you flirt
yeah let's go back to the role play
hello the two w's i would probably
say hi hi depending on how i feel
you know what i would say hi hi l-u-v
love uh-huh oh that's nice
okay that's easy we'll just do it like
this no text this is bar conversation
you're you hey you are you
this is a male yep now let's go
how are you doing i'm good um
the [ __ ] is blessing yo you
like her bro you [ __ ] like that's the
way he does it i'm telling you
[ __ ] is blessings [ __ ] oh my god
an old lady that's been locked in a cave
for 36 years
what are blessings damn with a wacker
he has a poisonous apple in his pocket
right now what is this blessing you say
do you have a wish
[Laughter]
oh this is a disaster
something whoa happy that's going on in
her life
um just you know the book the big movie
oh so excited i'm gonna go to vancouver
for three months what movie
i can't say too much right now oh you're
that famous yeah it's
hashtag let me ask you something when
people get mainstream fame
they really surpass us like like no
tomorrow
they never come back on the show i'm
just saying that i understand
if you if you do this i will always go
back no no no don't because
it's bad for your career so far so if
this is a movie we have to sabotage
everything for her to not get on that
back because we want her back she's one
of our favorites she's not going to
vancouver
that's how we show love here right you
we are we
we are dangerous to you we are we are
risky to your career to your career
have you seen the things i've already
said well luckily this movie
is in the lane of everything i've
already said okay cool it's a shitty
movie
parts flirting was that he thought it
was a legit conversation so he came in
and started talking
baby you got to up it dude i'm a natural
i think okay let's let's let's let's
let's
uh switch it up geo and i yeah
i'm a um
i'll be like um like i'll i'll
you text me first okay hey baby what's
up ah
this is just different she already wants
[ __ ] okay this is so
okay this is just different those are
just look at this look at this is so
[ __ ] wet it sounds like a faucet is
on right now dude
no there's a kid with a [ __ ] there's
a kid with a thick shoe sliding out of
my [ __ ] right now
her [ __ ] is a broken new york fire
hydrant you have a [ __ ] predator
mouth [ __ ] and [ __ ]
that's hilarious he's playing around
your [ __ ] right now is what he's saying
a hot day a hot day a hot day
that's just weird let's do the other way
let's do it you got to do it the other
way you have to engage versus her saying
something to you okay
can i just say there is just something
unbeatable about
female female romance that's true i
agree
[Laughter]
a hundred percent yes
no that's why i like watching that porn
that's right me and this girl on our
first date we were just like
we our cheeks were hurting like we could
not stop smiling
like we were just so my cheeks were
hurting and there skips at you
that you skip which cheeks bottom cheeks
why are they hurting daddy
cuz i got it but you know you don't ever
smile like that when you're talking to a
dude
i do what are the steps that you skip
because your walls are not there's less
defense or something i mean let's think
about it
when we grew up like our first best
friends female yeah we could skip
through a lot of [ __ ]
you know what i mean it's like there's
understanding there's there's mean girl
quotes
you know i mean the movie mean girls
quotes like this is like
a language that women speak mean girl
quotes go we wear pink on
thursdays fridays wednesdays on
wednesdays we wear pink
on wednesdays we wear pink um that was
smooth
maybe maybe a gig i could just pop
right like imagine like if we went out
to the shooting range we're like
and then we will [ __ ] reach over we
[ __ ] make out hot
there aren't like it's like disgusting
don't confuse the two good gods um
that's just dangerous romance whatsoever
that's why i think it'd be worse
actually it's two dudes their walls are
up they don't have that
i think there's extra steps now they
don't skip steps that is interesting and
like unfortunately
excuse me unfortunately we don't have a
gay man here to chime in but david
i feel like as he crosses his smooth leg
i feel like straight men always have
like this weird perception of what gay
men are because when you go to like the
west hollywood you target these gays oh
yeah
then being here i always have the shadow
[ __ ] stereotypes that
you guys think like the idea of two guys
popping gun to be like hey what's up
honey
that's just gay guys it's totally like
the perception that gave it are so funny
from straight dudes you know
it's just hilarious that i just had this
image of this bullet just popping off
gun super slo-mo like [ __ ]
dubs flying in the air and it just goes
yeah
very gentle i mean mr mrs smith just
make it mr mr smith
right it's romantic mrs and mrs smith
do you think yeah let me ask you do you
think if two guys who are in a long
committed relationship they get into a
fist fight
that's like domestic violence or there's
just like two guys just fight two dudes
fighting
no that's domestic violence i think it's
always domestic violence
david own all your layers thank you
okay own all your layers mama i'm sorry
all right
well i'm sorry everything it's better
if there is assault in a romantic
relationship
is domestic violence i'll clear that up
no just because like i feel like what if
it's just in the butt area
guys hash it out very you know violently
yeah you know they'll suck each other up
and they'll be like i mean ghetto people
do that [ __ ] no
straight up ghetto okay when's the last
time you all got into a fight never
i got punched i love her where they're
punched why i instigated
so no okay y'all been to old town
pasadena 626 volcano you know that bar
area i used to work there
oh at volcano i know some people wait
server or bartender
dancer but the answer
yeah sometimes places hire a dancer to
start the dance floor yeah
that makes sense don't beat up his boss
yeah just say random facts and we'll
just all agree you're like if you all
you have to do is say
it's a gay thing and we're like we can't
argue with that
david's looking at me because he just
shook because it's like a reflection
when
will my re-relationship
right now right now you did that with
the most ashes
[Laughter]
unfortunately my throat is dryer than my
[ __ ] right now
unfortunately it's a different tube it's
a whole different tube it's a whole
different pipeline
um my doctor is my plumber um
no but that could work that could
absolutely work i'm not a scientist
but wait where were we uh you're talking
about uh
volcano so i literally it was packed
like sardines
in that area and i was talking to this
dude his name was peter i remember and
like we were kind of kissing
and then he and his friends uh were
standing there and it was so packed it
was this girl who like and i'm not tiny
but this girl was like
she could [ __ ] me up right like she was
taller like more had more muscle
um i know i was like you talk about me
dwayne johnson in a wig uh comes up and
kind of accidentally bumps me because
it's so packed and i just have liquid
courage
like for no reason i'm trying to fight
oh you [ __ ] so i did push her
she didn't push her you didn't even ask
like hey what happened no i should have
pushed her in a crowded place
i didn't say it you just excuse you no i
was just so lit and also 23.
you're violent i know no no you didn't
just go out only sometimes
um
[Laughter]
next time some [ __ ] wants to fight me
i'm just like
what would you do what would they do
[Laughter]
um but yeah so oh [ __ ] i'm pushing her
and then i start just swinging oh
[ __ ] can't see [ __ ] i'm just as dark
punching all the customers and [ __ ] no
reason for you to attack this person
i was feeling like chun li i was feeling
it she didn't even push you back you
just pushed her and just started
swinging i just was like open air
swinging and then she
boom oh and then i fall slow motion the
guys i was with
pick me up like maybe three feet from
the floor they catch me
i'm back up don't see her anymore eyes
are watery eyes eyes watery i've never
gotten hit in the face of my life
and then i i go out and find my friends
and then she's like my friend's like
wait what happened my best friend
christine she sees me and i was like do
i just
put punch in the face she's like what
and then
and then i did deserve it 100 so then i
see a girl outside that i think is her
with the same color jacket
and then you start [ __ ] with her i
push her again oh my
god and then i got um
kicked out the other eye no i got kicked
out i got kicked out no saki saki twice
twice you got kicked out
from the outside i've never heard that
get your ass
back in there
and go find the right person i got
double kicked out because it was like an
outdoor
area of the inside region a patio you
just saw a color and you're like that's
the person
that you went over there that jacket h m
fall 20 23.
uh 2023 that's the future um so then my
friend
my best friend's sister um
gets punched later at king taco
it's like a punch card guys are the
worst
not going out with all trash this was 2
000 and [ __ ] like nine sis
that's how people die
in the bathroom
you